welcome back to the show I'm Mark Ellis
and we have a returning favorite the
French tongue okay
speaking of returning champions we have
the rock he's back in another episode
and he still is not going to make it in
person
no looking for parking okay he's not
here that's unfortunate but I am and so
let's go ahead and pit the igneous one
versus a hilarious comic a box-office
star and a frequent collaborator of
Dwayne Johnson's mr. Kevin Hart they're
teaming up again for Jumanji to to
jungle to furious but today it's all
about whose career is more fire Kevin
Hart who I met a few times when I worked
the door of the comedy store he was very
nice or at the rock who one time
retweeted a friend of mine what here's
how it works
round 1 box office round 2 tomato meter
round 3 versatility and then we'll do a
wild-card round I'll render my verdict
and lastly I'll turn it over to you the
viewer for your vote ready to go the
winner plays Jack Black next let's get
it on
straight out of the brownie beating
pie-eating trailblazing I'm not raising
entertaining the glove never hotter
talking to 2 rejects from Harry Potter
whoa found one box office weather we're
going to the cinema for laughs
explosions or just the mindlessly shoved
popcorn in our faces for two hours both
the rock and Kevin Hart fit the bill
Dwayne came from the world of wrestling
to save the day on the big screen then
we found out he's really funny too
because I have a secret weapon people
actually like me Kevin came from the
world of stand-up to make us giggle on
the big screen then we found out he's
even funny in action flicks Kevin puts
up a good fight against Dewayne for the
best domestic box office numbers his
movies have grossed two combined three
billion dollars with a per flick average
of 94 million dollars that's just short
of Dwayne's domestic total of four point
three billion dollars and a hundred and
thirty-four million dollar per movie
average so we got us a good ball game
here right well then we go international
apparently giant action sequences travel
better overseas than the laughs as
evidenced by the rocks films grossing a
combined 12 point two billion dollars
worldwide woman
I have the Calvary Wow is that do we say
if we have that much money on earth
still meanwhile Kevin Hart's films have
done five point five billion dollars
total of business so when it comes to
box office I don't want to say that
Kevin has been torched by Duane so I
won't I will not say that hi Joe good
I'll just give rocky the wind and we'll
move on to round number two it just
happens naturally round number two
tomato meter this is a round Kevin Hart
needs to win in order for him to have a
chance and for this vid to be compelling
both fellas hover around the 50 percent
mark for their average movie on the
tomato meter the rock is at fifty point
three percent heart is forty five point
three percent if we look specifically at
comedies it gets a little more
competitive Kevin Hart's funny flicks
average forty five point seven percent
while Johnson's average forty six point
three percent Dwayne's best work
according to the tomato meter is
fighting with my family at 92 percent
his highest comedy is the hilarious the
other guys at seventy-eight percent you
thinking what I'm thinking party aim for
the bushes Kevin Hart has a perfect
hundred percent rating for his stand-up
special irresponsible although to be
fair it only has six reviews you
attacked my comedy special yourself was
bastard he's also one of the stars of
Captain Underpants and that's an 88% and
top 5 the Chris Rock film and he appears
in that's an 86% so look both gents have
some really good movies some of which
they've been in together and their
averages are neck-and-neck what's going
to determine a winner in this round is
who has the least amount of truly awful
garbage stinking up the bottom of the
vine
Kevin sets the bar really high low
whatever you want to call it with Little
Fockers it's currently 9 percent on the
tomato meter the rocks low bar is
another attempted family pleasing humor
the tooth fairy at 18%
so I guess because Dwayne's movie has a
higher score he'll get the win Inlet oh
wait a minute what's that I hear good
god that's big watches music yes the
rock starred in a movie that is truly
awful not just for our time
but for all times I scratch my back with
a whale's dick how that dead pile of
seaweed made it all the way to 18% on
the tomato meters beyond me and so now
that I'm presented with this new
information I cannot in good conscience
award this round to the rock Kevin Hart
taste the tomato leader said in an upset
and now we're tied at one apiece
[Music]
round three versatility this round feels
like a trap and despite Admiral Ackbar
yelling that in my ear I'm going to
continue who's more versatile got more
range who can do more things better
Kevin Hart not only is he a funny actor
he's a comic that sells out arenas all
over the globe which is two different
skill sets kiddies I don't trust people
they do this when they talk he also is a
producer he has his own company and
here's something that gets overlooked in
the films he stars in alongside the rock
like Jumanji and central intelligence
he's a really good straight man he
allows Dwayne to be the comedic one
I'm swaddling you know what you do
matters wonho to be a comic that is on
stage by yourself in front of tens of
thousands of people and then to be able
to check that ego at the door to a while
your co-star to shine that's impressive
what's even more impressive the rock I'm
offended his nickname is franchise
viagra for a reason and most people
would be content with that reputation
but with Dwayne that's just the tip of
the proverbial iceberg he's an athlete
wrestler actor producer and his social
media accounts are just a bit more
popular than Kevin Hart the rock has
more followers on Instagram and YouTube
while Kevin has more on the cessful of
darkness I'm sorry that's Twitter I uh I
read that wrong when you use a bird to
write with
it's called tweeting within the context
of movies Duane also is shown more range
he can play the tough badass the
charming spy the tough badass charming
spy I love your babushka but you can
also be the sensitive dad and
introspective coach basically Duane can
be anyone with a heart of gold on either
side of the law you're welcome plus he
can go insanely evil I can doom would
kill them all now anybody remember I was
am I not supposed to bring that up
Scorpion King anyone great effects both
gentlemen boasts an impressive amount of
versatility but at the end of the day
the rock does not sleep ever
like he doesn't sleep there's no way he
can hang on I'm just getting word now
he's also tequila magnate he's jeez well
then diesel is napping his life away the
rock continues to blaze a trail very few
could have predicted and leaves
footsteps that no one can follow and
that's the bottom line
oh yeah it's stone cold that's not well
I smell what The Rock is cooking and
that's a victory in round number three
wildcard round who's the better troll
okay so maybe the rock is more famous
versatile and overall heroic type but
when it comes to bro on bro tomfoolery
he has met his match with Kevin Hart
these two go at each other constantly
and the funniest most good-natured
surprising ways possible kevin has been
through some real life stuff recently
and Dwayne is always there to poke fun
in a Big Brother sort of way when Hart
had the Academy Awards controversy
Johnson joked that it was Dwayne who in
fact was the first choice then Kevin had
a life-threatening car crash and after
expressing his honest well wishes to his
buddy the rock then threw a jab by
saying that keV was safely strapped to
his car seat that's funny stuff
thankfully he was strapped in nicely to
his car seat but Kevin might have had my
favorite burn ever in picture form they
go back and forth a ton on social media
and when Hart made his Halloween costume
an exact replica of a pic from Dwayne
Johnson's University of Miami Hurricanes
days it won the Internet that is
hysterical like I just go to the costume
store say make me look
the rock was a good sport has plenty of
ammo to retaliate with including
bringing this childhood photo of Kevin
Hart
to his most recent appearance on Ellen
Show he's doing this I wish I was this
tall if you engage with social media
these two are likely the top reason why
they're back and forth represents a
roast battle yin and yang none would be
whole without the other so the only
reason I give this round to heart is
knowing him as a stand-up comic I know
the firepower he has to full-on crush a
heckler Dwayne is consistently funny
inspiring and active across all as many
platforms but when it comes to having
the ability to troll another person I
will always take the comic who is
shorter and has probably heard that all
his life because that person has an
unlimited supply of retaliation ready to
go kind of like The Rock's character
Luke Hobbs in the Fast and Furious
flicks this round is going to Kevin Hart
this case and I must say abracadabra
[ __ ] you're looking at the magic but
the match itself goes to Dwayne the rock
Johnson as much as they're a great team
I feel like the rock would be able to
link up with any number of comedic
forces and make magic together but Hart
what other action star is he gonna join
and get the same results with the rock
is a singular force on this planet that
should never be undersold scorchin I
hate this game that's just my opinion
folks now the real heavy lifting is up
to you vote now simply by commenting
below who do you love more who wins the
rounds in your eyes which actor would
you rather hang out with let us know and
if the rock or Kevin Hart are watching
just remember guys please never ever
ever stop making fun of each other
always do that and let us see it
especially it involves a fanny pack
the leather fanny pack to be exact have
a great day gang I'm French Chuck Ellis
and we'll see you next time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]